I got a message yesterday after I
covered a report that anti-depressants
are having all sorts of weird sexual uh
consequences on people this is the
message I got I found your video on
anti-depressants very interesting you
had mentioned that teenagers will never
develop sexual function and you're
correct I'm currently dealing with
permanent side effects from an SSR and I
would encourage you to check out this
website as what you said in your video
correlates to the problem so I clicked
on the link and it it took me to a
website about a condition called
pssd a condition of of these
consequences that affect sex and
emotions and really the whole
personality not just while people are on
these SSRI drugs but after they get off
them sometimes permanently long after
they get off the SSRI drugs and no one
seems to be talking about this one in
eight American adults is hooked on SSR
bu drugs and I I don't even need to
qualify it necessarily with among adults
because increasingly these drugs are
being prescribed to teenagers and kids
even
12-year-olds a huge number of Americans
are on these drugs there was a study
that came out some months ago that
suggests that the drugs don't work in
the way that we've been told that the
drugs work no one really knows how the
drugs work but we are seeing increasing
evidence that these these powerful
psychiatric drugs that a huge number of
Americans are on can have permanent
consequences and totally rewire people's
personalities post SSRI sexual
dysfunction or pssd is the current term
used to describe this phenomenon pssd
can manifest as a wide range of
neurological physical and sexual
symptoms among the most common symptoms
reported by sufferers are genital
numbness erectile disfunction vaginal
dryness a complete loss of libido an
orgasmia emotional blunting anhedonia
and cognitive impairment these and many
more debilitating symptoms can persist
for years decades or even become
permanent after discontinuing the
medication despite the acknowledgement
by various Health Care organizations
that sexual side effects can persist
many sufferers still have their symptoms
minimized and dismissed as a valid
Health Care concern currently there is
no effective treatment for pssd and
tragically some severely affected
patients have taken their lives so the
there are two keys to me here about this
explanation one this is not just some c
Fringe theory of of people who are
ascribing consequences to this this drug
that aren't really there this is
something that's acknowledged by the
European medicine agency by the NHS by
all sorts of Public Health bodies
they're saying yes yeah these drugs can
cause all these issues and they cause
all these sexual issues which is bad
enough sex is very important to human
nature and and so if you totally blunt
sex especially in super young people
especially in teenagers can you imagine
how awful that would be but then beyond
that what about the emotional blunting
what about the anhedonia the inability
to feel pleasure what about the
cognitive empowerment that comes from
these powerful psych drugs because
people don't want to engage in ordinary
therapy someone says oh you know I'm
feeling a little bit sad today uh rather
than engage in cognitive behavioral
therapy rather than talking to
a counselor or to a priest rather than
addressing the the spiritual concerns or
just the Practical everyday issues that
might be causing someone to feel a
little sad what does our culture do our
culture says oh good take a magic pill
yeah take this drug get hooked on drugs
and it might melt your brain and it
might screw up your entire sexuality and
it might deprive you of the ability to
feel pleasure or to think for the rest
of your life but hey at least then we
don't need to confront the problem just
take a pill and no one's talking about
this
that's insane the the public health
bodies are acknowledging that this is a
problem no one talks about it the the
rates of prescription just keep going up
we start prescribing it to
12-year-olds
absolute Madness right now go to
helixsleep.com slns with everything
going on in the world right now you
could really use a good night's sleep
that is why you need to check out Helix
mattress the Helix lineup offers 20
unique mattresses including the
award-winning Lux collection oo la la
the newly released Helix Elite
collection a mattress designed for Big
and Tall sleepers and even a mattress
made just for kids I have had my Helix
for years probably what 3 four years now
I absolutely love it night after night I
sleep so sweet so sound I want the same
for you Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress why
would you want to sleep in a mattress
made for someone else get out of my
mattress I'm a married man go to Helix
sleep.com
KW take their two-minute sleep quiz to
find the perfect mattress for your body
and sleep type their flexible payment
plans make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away Helix offers 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners helixsleep.com
use code Helix partner 2020 this is
their best offer yet it won't last long
Helix better sleep starts now the new
California Senator lefa
Butler she was the one immediately named
by governor Patrick baitman uh to fill
the seat vacated when Diane Feinstein
died she is the president of em EMILY's
List EMILY's List is a group that works
to elect pro-abortion women to public
office so she's a real she's a treat you
know this one her rais on Detra the the
uh thing that gets her out of bed in the
morning is just getting women elected
who are going to be more inclined to
murder babies uh this woman now is a US
senator but there's a problem which is
that she is the senator from California
but she doesn't live in California she
lives in Maryland and if you go to the
website of Emily's List her her Maryland
residence was listed there until they
scrubbed it in
mid-september Rob Pyers who research
director of the California Target book
looks at all these Finance filings uh
this woman was listed as being a
Maryland resident is recently is August
31st so is that going to take her out is
lansa Butler no longer going to be the
senator the senat Trix from
California uh no no one's going to Care
nobody's going to care at all
it used to be a really good attack in
politics to say that so- and so is a
carpet bagger you know he just moved
from DC to this District so he could win
Congress that would sometimes work
doesn't really work anymore because
national identity and ideological
identity perhaps even more so has
overtaken State
identity and the first part of that was
actually predicted and encouraged by the
founding fathers and the framers in the
Federalist uh the the puus you know
who's a an amalgam of Alexander Hamilton
and James Madison and John Jay they
wrote in the Federalist about how
initially in the early days of the
country State allegiances and State
identity are going to be tippity top but
then over time people are going to lose
a little bit of their flavor of their
state identity and take on more of a
national American identity well that's
happened no one really cares now you
know even for me if if there were a
really good conservative but he happened
not to be from my state but he could be
the senator for my state I'd strongly
consider voting for that
person what's a little dangerous though
not exactly encouraged by the founding
fathers and the framers is that
ideological identity has taken over
probably even American identities and
national identity such that probably The
Californians would be perfectly fine
having a senator from any country as
long as that Senator were as fanatically
dedicated to killing babies and to all
the other nonsense on their agenda as
lansa Butler and as they are and that
does not strengthen American national
identity that threatens its very essence
boy what array clip that was now make
sure that you ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel see you
next time